Hello my friends,
I wanted to teach you and tell you that Jean la Salle
has become the head of the list of the rural ellence.
We decided together to lead this fight.
It was obvious.
You know Jean,
he is a man of character.
It is this big mouth of our rural world.
It was necessary to be at least 2 so that the voice of
the forgotten would not be lost and would finally be heard.
Many of you wonder why I asked John to head the Ural Alliance list.
For me it was 1 obvious,
it is 1 charismatic man,
it is 1 man who has led many fights for a long time.
This is 1 man who conducted 2 presidential elections.
He is also a man for whom I have the greatest admiration and respect.
It is 1 gatherer,
it is the way of the rurality.
It is therefore behind him,
but with all of you,
that we will lead this fight for the European elections.
This is very, very important.